you know i'm i'm uh concerned about
something which is i know that you
you told me a while ago i think the last
time i saw you that you were going to
quit smoking this year
this is a tough year to quit smoking
they didn't pan out um you didn't quit
it's it's not the time i was reading a
few studies that said um
it actually it sort of protects your
lungs to smoke
um because you know from covid because
uh i think it toughens them up no so
i i just thought that medically it
wasn't the best idea or the best time
oh this was that famous marlborough
study that just came
out well do you know what i mean i just
um
trying to kind of you know that's why
you took up smoking
yeah like you i got all excited i
thought i gotta toughen up my lungs
um so i started chain smoking filter
unfiltered cigarettes from the 1930s
okay this is why robert mitchum's still
alive as we know
okay so he's a well-known survivor
and uh he's patient zero so
this is a obviously these are uh
atrocious times and and you know it's
it's uh harrowing that we're all living
through this
as if it's uh reasonable uh you know
i actually think in many ways i've never
been happier um
you know there's things i don't miss i
don't miss uh i never was interested in
going to
a brunch with anyone or meeting somebody
for coffee
you're not a social person you're not a
very social person you
as you said you like to hibernate you
want to go into a
into a cave with a lot of salmon in your
belly and just sleep through the winter
right that's what i like uh but uh
but fred is more active and that keeps
me young could you have more rings on
right now would that
be possible is there room for more rings
i'm gonna level with you i
i rarely am out of anything other than
you know
t-shirts and panties okay so the idea
that i had an opportunity
to actually put on all of my rings
and that there's no need here for like a
a full length you know what i mean that
would give
any indication of
i'm really enjoying that everything is
just um
so surreal conan i really it does it for
me
tell me tell me what are the things
because you've told me a lot of what you
don't like
what are like the three things you like
to do during
you know what makes you happy if you
just had to boil it down to three things
uh smoking okay swimming
and zelda the uh the the video game
yeah i play that for about i would say
12 hours a day i mean in place of sleep
because i'm a busy person but
um yeah i've been you know uh
just periodically renting these you know
uh shitty houses uh
in the valley that are just you know
they're bad but they have a pool
uh and because like i'm saying fred runs
around but i just moved from you know
the bed
to the balcony and you know to like
you know do conference calls and change
it's not a healthy lifestyle so i've
taken to
getting these uh you know weird places
and uh
i love to swim uh because you know my
joints are not great
and uh i like to get in the water move
around
obama quote like seven years ago where
he was like you gotta exercise 20
minutes a day and so i swim and i think
about obama
for 20 minutes and then you know i play
zelda for another seven hours
uh you know what it's so funny because
you are a young woman you're a young
vibrant woman
but you're coming across boobs
thank you what i said only in the boobs
i got boobs for days i got boobs like i
i i'm telling you um but you you channel
this
you do channel this woman who's uh in
her 60s and has a zabar's bag
and is wearing 95 rings and a bunch of
cats that's who you be
that's somehow times your personality
even though you're this this very young
vibrant attractive woman
you it seems like you can't wait to be
an old crazy lady you just can't wait
you know and why should i i mean i don't
have to
i just feel like you know we make up
these
rules you know i think about uh a young
gary oldman playing sid vicious at the
end of city nancy
nancy singing my way and i think you
know
uh what's the problem here there is no
problem there's only solutions so
how did you get from how did you get
from gary oldman playing sid vicious to
there are no problems
you know what conan get in here honey
get in here
okay